first before we jump into the other
topic so Who am I I'm Gustavo Franco a
que Stratus I've been with Google for
roughly 11 years now I work on the
custom reliability engineering team
which part of the answer organization
with social personal response for this
launch if you're watching here if you're
not watching at home let's cover some
assumptions Before we jump right into
like the have a necessary team how to
get to an SRE team I have a couple
assumptions and you can correct me if
I'm wrong I think hopefully most of you
here already familiar with what SOA is
and you probably at least have vaguely
on a bigger understanding of the
difference between sre and that wops if
you don't follow that link in there to
get more information about what we think
of the difference between a Serie of ops
the link structure here and we had a
position earlier at this conference from
Steph 4eva one of the developer
relations folks about the difference
between a straight dive ops which will
recommend you to watch if you haven't
watched it yet the the gist of it is we
say sre is an implementation of that
verbs a lot more information for you if
you follow that link and the third
assumption that I have is there's some
leadership buy-in vp's sea levels
actives have some by ants into either if
your manager if individual contributor
trying to implement adopt astray best
practices and implement an s3 team at
your company people generally agree with
it
so why are we here so first this can be
seen as a guided tour of the Google
essary workbook if you haven't read if
you hadn't read it yet we have a copy
online I'll have a link at the end we
also have some copies for you so after
this stock towards the end you can
actually get a copy from us as follow
this talk so the first things first this
we're here because I'm again I'm gonna
guide you through the some chapters of
the workbook in order to get there right
you got to get to your first SRE team
the second reason why we're here is I'll
give you concrete examples one thing
that we get feedback often about when we
talk about essary with customers like
yourselves is okay I understand the
practice I heard about SLS and SL O's
how do I really do it how do I get from
quote unquote nothing or an operational
team or a developer team that wants to
adopt sre to actual concrete tangible
action so we're gonna cover some example
some of quick examples there last but
not least we're here so we can use this
some kind of benchmarking so if you have
a three teams already you can kind of
compare notes with us I would like to
hear your feedback right after the
presentation through questions or just
we can go in the back and have a
conversation about it
cool so first things first I will go
through if you're just getting started
so you're sitting here and you don't
have a necessary team yet and you're
really interested in your doctor's your
best practice and you have a necessary
team we're gonna go through that I'll
also cover different SRA implementations
so different flavors of essary
and I also guide you through a
commissary practice by lavrov maturity
this is totally arbitrary I made this up
right if you say I go through advanced
and you're like no my team is doing half
of advanced and half a beginner where am
I at
I don't have an answer for you I just
have rough guidelines in terms of what I
see beginner teams at Google doing after
intermediate to intermediate teams and
advanced teams
and then of course what we should do
next so if you're just getting started
first recommendation is establish
service level objectives right so I
won't get into details of what this
means but it's of course you can see the
the link to the the chapter of the book
as I mentioned before as your access
presentation you can get a free copy of
the book or you could go to google.com
slash Missouri to read a chapter one
thing I will say about Celsius lows and
while it's so important if you're
getting started even if you don't have a
three-team yet is how is it there you're
gonna just five prioritizing stability
over feature velocity if you don't know
where your bar for reliability is at
your bar has to be anything other than
100 percent my colleague his who's was
just explaining the previous
presentation so hopefully some of you
caught that second thing that we
recommend folks to do is adopt blameless
post-mortems it's very easy some
companies some it's very easy some
companies for people to buy into that
and some other companies people like
know if someone makes a mistake I still
think we should quote-unquote punish
them somehow if you are one of those
companies if you're working one of those
companies where people want to
quote-unquote punish folks because they
make honest mistakes so it's really hard
to adopt limits post-mortems so if you
cannot change that culture maybe a sari
is it's not for you it's not for your
company maybe it's not gonna help you
it's not gonna work so back to you one
thing to consider establish a SLIC salos
establishment blame us for small rooms
establishing blameless postman's is our
ball culture it's not technical and if
the company culture is now already
you're gonna have a problem adopting
your dress or your best practices
basically the third one is once you have
blameless post-mortems establish a
process to manage production incidents
why a process well you don't want people
to be page at 3:00 a.m. you don't want
to be people being paid in all the
weekends and they don't know what to do
with that pager so if you have a slicer
solos you have blemish post-mortems dark
manual process to respond to pages we
we often see as three teams the story
functions where people have a top
satellizer solos they have they write
books more than half the price of
writing post-mortems whatever people get
page they don't know what to do so train
your folks establish a process and back
to this chapter covers more details or
things to to do there all right we cover
things that if you're just getting
started so three things but I understand
not every team is created equal
maybe you're able to do two or three and
it might be okay I step from maybe
bloomers post Morris because you might
have code for issues or your company
let's talk about why not every story
team is created equal
I see commonly five to six as three
different flavors different different
implementations and that's where people
get Conoco a little lost because they
say oh I do a sorry but I don't
necessary quite like Google and I say
well how do you do a sorry and after
they tell me how they do a story and I
say no yeah we have several teams at
Google that are just like yours
it's just Google has an entire
organization we have very different
implementations of sorry inside of
Google so guide you through some of the
ones that I've seen both at Google and
outside Google the first one is I think
it's interesting to highlight is
consulting so consulting is you may have
a couple s eries they're consulting with
developers on their design they might be
consulting on Kotaku frequent
configuration changes they might be
consulting on the instant response and
blamers post mourners on the finding SL
s and s ellos but enough they at the end
of the day consultants don't tend to get
color code their hands dirty with
changing configuration changing code
that's why they're called consultants
this is okay if is all you can afford if
that's why you want a plumeria your
company you can have a necessary team
your first israeli team can be of
consultants we talked about some of the
main risks i've seen in consulting teams
in a moment
second implementation embedded teams so
embedded teams you have their general
you don't matter an entire team your
embedded in the videos of a team so you
may have a team of five folks five s
eries 1-2-3 and embedded with each write
one or two each are embedded with
different developers working with them
right we also have those at Google so if
you have this or your company or say I'm
not doing it's very quite like Google
yes you are and it's okay so that's one
implementation it's totally acceptable
that could be your first team you could
have one two folks to be embedded there
generally the difference between a
battery consulting is we don't see we do
see a better folks going hands-on like
changing codec or fake they may or may
not be on call with the team but back to
you it's your implementation you define
it you define the details the third and
the fourth one that kind of burner
together because they tend to be similar
are the tools or the aim for a story
team so the tools or the infra setting
is this sa team that specialized on
either a set of tools or so they built
tooling for the developers for the
company reliability tools maybe monitor
related tools maybe SLI Salo related
tools instant response to blame blame
was post-mortem tools or they could be
an infrastructure a story team where
they're responsible for let's say your
now you're running on GK or you have
your own company kubernetes cluster
cluster so that infrastructure a story
team may be responsible for the color
code infrastructure not the application
slice is when you get a slice of your
problem space at the company it could be
a product right a single product is a
slice or a set of products a product
area so those are a three teams that
they're responsive forests slice of the
problem kitchen sink or everything tends
to be the most common that I see in
other companies where in especially when
they're in the beginning of the answer a
journey that's the first a sorry team so
they tend to name the team after the
company so if you're a company and you
name your s3 team company a sorry and I
ask what is this a switching responsible
for you say everything that's what I
would consider to be a kitchen sink
implementation
I'll leave it up there a little bit
because I see a couple folks taking
photos of the implementations will cover
main risks and a little bit of about
don't call and team size which people
ask me quite a bit about before we get
into that one way to scare people ask me
often right like okay what is the right
implementation what is the right mix it
depends
one thing that I've seen folks scaling
some of these implementations in place
especially tools in for its lights and
kitchen sink is cheers of service what
does that mean you might tell your
developers hey you know what I cannot be
on call I can do I cannot do project
work on everything that we have at the
company and even though I'm responsible
for slice or tools or infra it's too
much we have too many tools we have too
much infrastructure or we have the slice
is too big so I've seen people adding
tiers of service so you have you can
imagine a first tier where you say I'm
just gonna do consulting a second tier
where you do project work and then
eventually a 30 or you don't call those
tiers are defined per company so you can
write down as part of your team charter
or a separate documentation where you've
got a glue memory over the developers
where the tiers means and which service
is going to be in each tier it's a it's
a way to help you to scale so it kind of
goes - you're going from zero to one
team but you might be like oh I feel
like I need 5's three teams all at once
you may not need to go from zero to five
and consider implementing tiers of
services
so people ask me about team size at Hong
Kong I'll just go through this quickly
the the gist of it is Google has
recommendations in the books about
minimal uncle size and etc in reality
companies are tend to be a lot smaller
especially in the beginning when they
opt in yessiree so we cannot really give
you a hard and fast rule like here the
minimum for every single implementation
or fast research you should have
consulting embedded you can start with
one answer if you like if that person is
not gonna be on call and there are no
concerns of burning that person out on
call you're totally fine but if you have
to have 24/7 on call we do a Google
recommend every team to that follows the
sir to have a sister team so six plus
six and minimum or a total twelve so
that's on the books but back to it
depends right it's a company thing so I
don't have a set formal for you let's go
to the main risk of each implementation
which I think can help you if you're at
zero team and you want to get to your
first team so hopefully that will help
you to decide what should be your first
implementation so for consulting the
more consultants that you have if you
don't have anything else it may be
perceive as the team may be perceive as
hands off because you're telling folks
what to do you're not doing it right so
in the long run the more you add
consults is really hard to scale their
impact they cannot really go deep on the
other problem space people gonna be like
oh yeah the asteroid consultants are
great but we cannot have 50-100
consultants in keep adding consultants
indefinitely the penny or your company
space back to you if you have a team of
consultants working well for your
company you're measuring success however
you measure success internally that's
that that's also fine I'm just listing
the risks that I've seen them based on
my personal experience embedded me the
individuals in an embedded team may
suffer from lack of knowledge sharing
let me tell what that means several
colleagues of my colleagues of money
different companies they tell me because
they have some embedded teams and one
common struggle is they send one essary
they have a team of ten people they send
one a sorry
to ten different developer teams and
it's really hard to get those as three
individual stories back into a meeting
room to share their experience so that's
a risk if you're not doing that then
eventually those individual stories
they're in battle the teams they feel
like such a part of the developer team
they're a battle with that they struggle
to come back and kind of have this sre
identity which tends to be a problem
because they are not sharing their sre
experience with each other so some
things to watch out for if you adopt an
embedded strategy for tools or
infrastructure the only risk I've seen
is the scope might be too narrow for
what the company needs right if your
company has several applications and you
only have one a story team and they're
focusing on tools and infrastructure it
may be too narrow for them for slice
it's similar to tools but one thing that
it may be opposite is if you keep adding
sliced teams right it's really hard to
scale just by adding extra slice teams
essary teams to your company and last
but not least kitchen sink works really
well in the beginning right you have a
team and their scope is basically a
bounded it's everything they can help
out with everything as the company grows
as a problem space grows that teams
impact and their abilities to understand
things deeply diminishes so you see the
deep impact going from deep to very
shallow impact and why is that well
because there's just too much work to do
right so if the scope enzyme about it so
one thing that we see is people start of
kitchen sink and then they eventually
staff consultants or embedded teams or
they actually start slicing their
kitchen sink into two right so they have
two slices cool so now let's go back for
implementations to core malpractice for
most implementations right we'll give
you more concrete examples based on
maturity and Kumo practice I'm seeing a
story team's adopting and links to the
book so then you can kind of you know as
you're browsing the SRU workbook
I don't Google Doc or slashes three or
one of the copies that we have in the
back you make more sense for you do what
I'm talking about
so begin your teams so first things
first try staffing plan should have me
in place so how is it they're gonna fund
the scene how many people you need so we
talked about this in the book the team
may or may not be on call right so keep
that in mind you may have an
implementation that does not require on
call on call is something that we say
essary
does may do but several stories are not
necessarily on call so you don't need to
have your original call to say I have a
necessary team that's not a requirement
we also generally see beginner teams to
start putting a release process and
canary row back where it's applicable
right so we understand mobile
applications you may struggle to have a
canary but you have a process to which
you may have a server side feature
control so but generally speaking answer
is tend to start being concerned about
release process in that beginner stage a
play book or one book write like the
most common term is in place and you do
some kind of disaster recovery tasks
which we also see often beginner teams
doing some kind of disaster career
testing it can be theoretical in the
beginning you may not have software to
do any kind of quote-unquote chaos
engine or any activity and as trees may
be doing at that point some kind of
independent project work in the beginner
phase that may or may not be visible by
the developer counterparts so this is
important right in the very beginning as
which may be doing work to automate oil
right that the developer maybe even
unaware of my recommendation for you is
back to you god leadership manager I
remember the assumptions the beginning
of the talk well if you're just having
impact the developers cannot see your
syllabus actors or VPS cannot see you
may be doing great but this is bad right
so you want to have some kind of
eventually project work that is going to
be seen the impact can be measured right
so in the beginning of phase it's okay
you might be able to make toil for
yourself but I would also recommend you
to look into your first team are they
doing work that positively impacts the
business that can be measured
by the rest of the organization and
healthier sorry teams regardless if
you're in the beginner stages if you're
just really implementing a sorry best
practices at the top they have enough
on-call load meaning if you are on call
there are pages but you're not on call
overload we have a ton of guidance on
the book or what we think is gonna
overload at Google what we think of what
is on cover like Google may be different
at your company people might be more
comfortable with more pages more alerts
per comfort with and a lot less than we
have at Google you need to define that
right you need to measure that
yourselves and another super important
thing that should actually be the title
of this talk that I've seen healthier
sorry teams is a team charter so let's
talk a little bit about team charters
it's the Constitution the definition of
the scope of the team back to the
kitchen sink a Surrey team if you just
start a necessary team and you don't
have that document you're not writing
down your scope your scope is some
powder your scope is everything and we
hate that in soft engineering so why
would we as sres apt like oh sure you
know anything the company needs in terms
of work that may or may not be related
to a sorry we will do define your
boundaries define your scope sure your
boundaries may move as the business
needs move but you probably run to write
this down and it's better for everyone
to understand your play need to
understand your work to understand your
implementation right is a kitchen sink
is it slice and so and so forth and that
gets me to you then if you have a
charter here the discussions that
leading to writing our team charter gets
you to have some kind of a story and
they have alignment and that's when
you're gonna see the misalignment right
things that you disagree with your
developer leadership or your sea levels
actives on the priorities for production
and what the SLO should look like if
people really buy into not aiming for
that unachievable 100% of uptime and
joint planning execution is also
something that we see in healthy teams
so back to if you're developers
you're as actives bought into yeah we
cannot achieve a hundred percent of
uptime
the team charter for the SAE team is
great and they're doing a joint project
work with the developers so all of a
sudden ya s re can be a successful
implementation of that verbs let's go to
intermediate essary teams right so
that's I cover the beginning and I cover
a little bit about what I see in healthy
SR teams regardless if they're in the
beginner stages or not
well the SLO that you sat at the top is
going to be reviewed and change right
generally I recommend every six months
or so but then again whatever works for
your company if you need like a rule of
thumb every six months review your SLO
so the business players might have
changed your customers might be more
strict or less strict and so you want to
review that with your business owners
like review your metrics your objectives
we also seen the intermediate teams they
start being able to measure that they
have some low volume of Toyo my Toyo
meaning the work that could be automated
or some impression of work that you
don't want to automate at all there are
definitions of toil I know out there
it's a contentious issue but the way you
define Toyo we tend to say well you know
half of the time for necessary team
should be spent on soft engineering
related or systems related project work
right well the other half or last is
then Toyo can you measure that so
intermediate as three teams tend to
start being able to even measure that we
don't see that as much in the beginner
stages the last point here is you start
reviewing incidents and the actual
dinosaur those instance right because
the establish Blaine was post-mortem
practice of beginning so now you start
being able to look at you have the time
you have the clinical this slack right
for project work for starting January
for systems engineering work you're not
drawing your employ you're an
operational work anymore well what is it
that you can do with the extra time well
one of things you can do the extra time
is let's pause and evaluate the action
items that we have for incidents and
still fewer prioritize the right things
to mitigate duplicate incidents
and at the end of the day as a little
violations start to have consequences so
what does that mean it doesn't
necessarily mean a freeze even though we
have recommend a freeze often by freeze
meaning stop launching new features if
you completely exhaust your SLO any
faster reliability several business that
I work with they say we can't we can't
afford do that what else can we do well
can you at least dedicate more resources
to improve reliability if you cannot
stop completely hard your pushes for new
features for new launches because you
have contracts you have commitments can
you at least invest some of the
developers time to improve reliability
because at the end of today right if the
product is completely down where is not
meeting the SLO the customers are
leaving you so SLO violations have
consequences so that's one thing that is
common for intermediary teams the
consequences you have to define them
within your company
we do recommend cause future launches
but I know it doesn't always happen some
kind of capacity planning is in place
right so if you're in the cloud if
you're using Google Cloud you understand
your Coda's you're working with your
account team and you understand organic
versus inorganic grow if you have you
may or may not have some software and
stories might have delegated to another
team but we see often answer is being
concerned about that some kind of
capacity planning is in place and it
could be purely quota planning for
Google cloud last but not least for
intermediary teams I also see a lot of
strategic planning so people start
writing roadmaps thinking about like not
just the neck the neck scrum cycle if
you're on screen or agile or the next
quarter pillars talking about like what
is it that we want to achieve by the end
of the year as an SRE team
let's switch quickly to then advanced
astray teams major positive business
impact at least one person to SR is that
can claim that because of the work there
is some major positive business impact
back to you if you're a sole eyes are
tuned with business metrics and answer
is are working to maintain or improve
the business reliability well it checks
out right answer you should be able to
claim some major positive impact
on the the business and scalable logic
work meaning Ansari's if in the
intermediate beginner phases they are
trying to tack home one service at a
time one promise space at a time they
switch to now or some parts of your team
it's or switch to a horizontal impact
meaning they don't work just on one
service with one team at a time they're
starting to come up with solution that
positively impact several services
several teams several developer partners
at once and SLO board based alerting
using place this one here I would love
to have that back in the beginners place
but I'm being realistic right ideally
you would have that for like every
beginner essary team that I see they
have some kind of alerting that is a
solo base I will be lying to you if I
said that's where the I think the sree
practice is at I think that's where
that's one that we should move to the
beginning and we're not there yet but if
you can help me please please please
work on SLO burn based learning and why
is that because people look at your
alerts right now and you get alerted
there's probably so many packs to the
system but do you know if your customers
are unhappy and are you measuring for
like how much time they're unhappy and
back to like linking to the his
presentation my colleague before about
SLO stright you need to tune them so if
you don't have a slow burn based
learning which kind of for learning you
have and are you happier if you're
learning and or your customer is happy
if you're learning is it tune with the
customer experience the last one this
one is some kind of ultimate disaster
recovery testing so then we see folks
talking about chaos you generate quite a
bit right so it's something that I see
more in advance sre teams where they
understand what is it that they can do
there is too radical disaster recovery
testing or for an injection and they
understand what is it that they're going
to do in on production systems and what
is they're gonna do in production and
eventually they have some kind of
automated system to stress test their
SLO
cool so now at the point a presentation
that people might be wondering what
should I do next what do i do from here
so first things first read the SRA
workbook will open from Q&A shortly but
if you're leaving please get a copy of
the the workbook it's by the door now
and read about Siri read about my team I
have a leave the slide slides be
available after the year the
presentation you can just google go Siri
and there's a whole blog post explaining
in details what we do and contact your
account manager if using having some
version of this talk and also more
information about SLO sandy Stern
response from customer liability
engineering engineers like myself so
Esther is working with you with the
customers so contact your account
manager about that and right now you can
just ask questions if you have any
[Music]
you
you